as if we didn't already think that the
Trump administration doesn't really
really care about making school safer
but really cares about political
posturing and optics and pandering to
gun lobbyists Donald Trump's top advisor
Stephen Miller fell asleep during a
meeting at the White House about school
shootings yesterday a bunch of Governors
went to the White House and Donald Trump
spoke about gun violence at high schools
it was all a response to the parkland
Florida shooting and Jim Liu Scalzo
who's a photographer for the European
press photo agency has this amazing
series of pictures of Stephen Miller
completely asleep then waking up rubbing
his eyes yawning looking like he fell
asleep like in his living room just
watching TV woke up and the president is
giving a speech about how we're gonna
try to prevent little kids from being
killed at schools and as soon as I saw
the headline Stephen Miller falls asleep
at Trump's speech on guns I thought this
has got to be absolute and total very
fake neat oh wait a second yeah he's
completely asleep in the picture it
actually occurred to me you can't really
prove someone is sleeping all we can say
is that he appeared to be completely
asleep but it's possible that he was
pretending for some reason like the
equivalent of a petulant child
expressing contempt for whatever their
parent is doing the only other
possibility other than Miller slept
through it is he was pretending to be
asleep to show that he was mad at Trump
for talking about gun violence or
something like that I was gonna say
something here but when I worked at
Circuit City the body language that
Miller is pictured exhibiting here would
get you suspended right if you stood out
on the sales floor during the work day
with this body language you would be
sent home Stephen Miller is a top
advisor to the President and he's
sleeping at major speeches by the
President of the United States and this
is the normalization of what's going on
right one of the top people right now
guiding policy in the United States who
already is a totally unqualified 30 year
old slept during a meeting about dead
kids and what gun safety regulation
should
yeah and reportedly Wilbur Ross doses
off from time to time at cabinet
meetings always have Trump is not happy
with that so this could put Stephen
Miller on Trump's bad side is that true
falling asleep apparently also sleep
during though that's crazy
I should really mention this as well the
other speculation about Miller has been
drug use if you remember that bizarre
interview he had I think it was with
Jake Tapper on CNN yes he he seemed like
maybe he was on the under the influence
of something but it always seems like
uppers right he doesn't seem like a
Downers guy and sleeping is more of a
Downers thing
the only explanation would be he had
been awake for three days straight on
uppers and then during this speech he
was crashing and that's why he fell
asleep or something like that I don't
know any any silver lining here like
maybe I don't know sleeping is better
than masturbating during the me I'm just
trying to find some some positive things
you're probably better if he is asleep
because he can't do horrible things
right I don't think you're not conscious
that's true
I really don't know that there are any
actual silver linings to the to the
reality the the disgusting reality that
a top adviser is sleeping at meetings
about really major things right the
reason Trump was doing this meeting with
governors and giving this speech is
because we had one of the worst school
shootings in American history recently
in parkland Florida and we're trying to
figure out how the hell can we solved
this thing just it's a comedy of errors
it's a gong show I don't know what to
call it but it's not good and the world
is laughing the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as $1 per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad